Roomann-Kurrik:
Thanks.
My name's Arne.
This is Chris.
And we both work
at Google.
To talk a little bit more
about who we are,
Chris is a developer advocate
here.
And I'm a developer programs
engineer.
We both worked
on Friend Connect,
and we both created websites
that have deep integrations
into the Friend Connect system.
Let's talk about who we're
expecting you guys are
in the audience today.
You're probably Web developers.
That much should be consistent.
You probably have
some experience
working on server-side
languages too.
So you probably work with Java,
PHP, Ruby, and Python.
You probably have experience
with SQL
or some sort
of database systems.
You probably have
an existing website.
Users probably go
to your website
to do some sort of task.
Maybe they share information.
Maybe they store information.
Maybe they interact
with other people.
And you probably have
an existing database
of registered accounts,
so people probably go
to your website,
fill out a form,
give you some information,
and then log in using
the credentials
that they give you.
And maybe you've heard
about Google Friend Connect,
and you don't really see how
it integrates into your site,
and so that's what we're here
to tell you today.
Maybe you've gotten
a few questions
about Friend Connect.
Maybe you want to know
does it let users sign
into my existing
registration system?
What users can sign in
if I put Friend Connect
on my website?
Can I deliver
a social experience
for all of my users
through Friend Connect?
And does Friend Connect enable
me to send invitations out
to other social networks
so I can spread my site
and grow adoption?
And--sorry.
Obviously the answer
to this is yes.
It does all of these things.
Friend Connect
is what I like to consider
a meta social network.
That means it basically takes
a lot of social networks,
and mostly OpenSocial networks,
and reads and writes
to them.
It can also read
from Portable Contacts sites
and basically aggregates
all this data together
into its own social network.
And on this platform,
it actually exposes
a set of APIs,
both client-side
and server-side,
that let you integrate deeply
with your website.
Um, also Friend Connect
has no icon,
so that makes it
really difficult
to have a visual indicator
for it.
So I just use the blue box
with the GFC.
Just so you're aware.
Maybe you haven't actually seen
Friend Connect in action,
so I'm gonna do
a really quick cut-and-paste
integration
with Friend Connect on an
example, hypothetical website,
just to get it out of the way
so we can move on
and see what we can do
beyond that.
The site in question
I like to call "Plane Crazy."
Maybe it's, you know, a site
for people who really like
flying small aircraft.
And so it's kind
of like a database.
It has a few planes in it,
information, statistics,
and you can see
it's a fairly simple UI.
It has the list of planes.
It has a few links
on the right.
It has a Google Search box.
Et cetera.
So now how would we go about
integrating this
with Google Friend Connect?
And so, first of all,
you go to the sign-up site,
and then you click a link
and you fill out some
information about your website,
give it the URL
and the name.
Then you have two files,
and you're gonna download
those two files
to your server,
and basically these two files
enable Friend Connect
to work anywhere
in your site.
So what I'm doing right now
is just uploading the FTP.
Now we're gonna install
the Members Gadget.
The Members Gadget
actually shows a list
of people who are on your site
and gives you some Chrome
to log in and out.
So what I'm doing
is actually downloading
my CSS file from my site,
just so I can take a look
at the colors
that I'm using
in the template.
And I'm just cutting and pasting
a few of the select colors
so that I can customize
this Members Gadget
Schalk: And see--oh, I just got
to say this is the beyond--
the part, the cut-and-paste, and
so just to kind of set it up,
and then after we do this,
we're gonna get
into the beyond section
where you have to do
more interesting service-side
integration.
Roomann-Kurrik: Right.
So I'm just going through
and customizing some
of these gadgets just to get
bare social functionality
into my site.
You can see here I'm actually
typing in a few divs
and stuff into my layout.
I'll actually put in
a little hello box,
so when I go back to the site
and refresh,
you can actually see
there's a new little sidebar,
and that's where I'm gonna put
the Members Gadget.
I go back in,
I paste in the code
that Friend Connect gave me,
I click back to this site,
and I reload.
And all of a sudden,
now I have a member site.
Members Gadget.
People can actually click
into my site,
and then sign in,
and, look,
I'm signing in
with my Google credentials,
so that I didn't have to put any
of this log-in
registration code.
And I'm clicking a button.
And now I'm a member
of this site.
Fairly straightforward.
Now it would be nice--
most sites have something
in the top right-hand corner,
kind of like a log-in/log-out
set of bar links.
So I'm gonna go back
to the Friend Connect site,
and I'm gonna reconfigure
yet another piece
of cut-and-paste functionality.
So here I am just changing
the color of the links
to match my site.
I'm changing
the background color
to match the little bar
that I want to put in there,
and I'm also removing
the border
so that it blends seamlessly
into my site.
Again, I get
some code generated.
And I'm gonna go type it in
to the div on my site.
Just put in a little bit
of Chrome,
you know, a shadow,
make it look nice.
And then, when I reload,
you'll actually see
a sign-in/sign-out bar,
my icon,
my name, et cetera,
is in there.
Looks pretty good.
One more thing
I'd really like
to put into this is--
you're looking
at a detailed page of a plane,
and I'd like users
to comment.
You know, kind of say things
about the plane.
Say why they like it.
So I'm gonna put in
what's called a Comments Gadget,
and I'm just configuring it here
again, doing the same thing
that I've done before
with the colors.
And you can actually see
the gadget updating
as it would normally,
just like the other gadgets did.
And I'm gonna take that
and let people actually come
to my site,
log in with Friend Connect,
and then leave a comment
about a certain plane.
And the great part about this
is that the integration
is very direct.
I mean, this movie's
a little bit sped up.
It's about 50% sped up,
but it's 3:39 long,
so, theoretically,
you should be able to get
a Friend Connect site
up and running
in under eight minutes
if you know what you're doing.
It might take you
a little bit longer.
That's fine.
Finally, you can see,
the Comments Gadget
is in there.
I'm just gonna leave a comment
about the plane.
Say,
"This is a really great plane."
You can see comment uploads
and refreshes, et cetera.
So this is the cut-and-paste.
We're gonna show you
how you can actually take
these ideas
and take these gadgets
and then integrate it
in a way that's more meaningful
and deeper into your site.
So you're not using
JavaScript anymore.
You're actually using
your own scripting languages,
your own data store,
et cetera,
to float this social information
back to the front end
of your site.
Before we actually get to that,
though,
let's talk a little
about why you would want
to use Friend Connect
as opposed to using
any other system
for doing this.
First off,
if you're a website owner,
you're probably
a social developer anyway.
Websites are social apps
because people come to them,
they interact,
the things that they do
on the site
usually are surfaced
in the UI,
and then people will actually
see what other users
of the site have done.
You can actually pull data
from web services,
you can mash stuff up.
It's very much
like a social application
that you'd run on Facebook
or an OpenSocial container.
And vice-versa too.
Because you're a social,
you know, website,
you're probably built
on a bunch of platforms.
Platforms are kind of like
the APIs of the Web.
There's a lot of them.
Especially if you're dealing
with OpenSocial containers.
If you want to let users
from OpenSocial
come into your site,
you're gonna have to deal
with several social networks.
There's how many now?
[laughter]
Schalk: Quite a number.
Opensocial.org, you can see all
the OpenSocial ones at least.
Roomann-Kurrik: Right.
So the users can come
from any point of integration
with your APIs, so if you have
an integration with Flickr,
there's a chance that Flickr
users will come to your site
just because
of that integration.
It means that your website
is kind of dependent
on existing platforms,
and there's so many of them,
so you have to be
cross-platform.
Like OpenSocial.
Here's actually a list
of some of the partners.
When OpenSocial was brought out,
it kind of gave an API
for simplifying
a social application
development,
so when you're building
a website
that needs to interface
with a social network,
now your choices are very large.
It can be almost too large
because there's a fixed cost
for integrating
with the social network.
For example, you have
to deploy your app.
You usually have to sign up
for a key
or registration.
You have to do
per-platform support,
so some platforms actually
make you have a user forum
just so you can support
your app there, et cetera.
So when you're thinking
about a traditional
cross-platform model,
like you compile
one application,
and then you install on
a bunch of different platforms,
it doesn't really work
that way anymore.
It's not, like, what containers
am I installed on?
It's more, like,
who do I talk to?
Where are the network bits
kind of going
and where are they coming from?
And then when you're thinking
about it in that model,
why not think about it
in terms of
what am I actually doing
with each network?
So, for example, you might be
sharing activities
with three different networks,
and you might be sharing
profile data with two networks,
and your application might
actually have views
embedded on other networks.
So the great thing
about this
and what Friend Connect offers
you is that it gives you
one set of common APIs
to kind of do all of this.
It sits in front of activities,
so that when you're posting
activities,
you post it to one place.
Those activities go out
to all the different sites
that are configured
with Friend Connect.
In fact,
it's pretty transparent.
Or, actually,
it's not transparent.
It's pretty opaque to you
because you just make
the one call
and Friend Connect
does all the heavy lifting
of figuring out
which networks to post to,
et cetera.
Also Friend Connect gives you
other things.
It gives you
some additional information
that you can surface
in your website.
There's some extra tools
and stuff
to make your site more social.
We'll definitely cover that.
And it gives you some views.
So if you're actually writing
views of your application
that run inside
of social networks--
for example, if you have
a website,
but you also have a gadget
that runs inside of Orkut
or MySpace, you can actually
surface your gadget
into Friend Connect itself also.
We actually had another talk
yesterday about this.
And you should
definitely check it out
once the slides
are posted online
about writing gadgets
for Google Friend Connect.
Let's talk about why you would
want to put Friend Connect
on your server, though.
Well, basically, it gives you
certain, very strong advantages.
It gives you
Google Friend Connect users
to log in for the first time
as if they were already
registered on your website.
So when a Google Friend Connect
user comes into your site,
they don't have to fill out
that form,
they actually have
a user account already
on your back-end system.
You have user IDs,
you have information about them.
It also gives you
social signals.
So you can highlight appropriate
content based off of what
a user's been doing
on your site
and what their friends
have been doing on your site.
Finally--
or not finally,
it uses content
to make new social connections
between the users
of your site.
So around the context
of the content on your site--
for example, Plane Crazy,
it's planes.
You might be able
to meet and interact
with people
that you wouldn't normally,
and that actually makes
your website way more valuable
for the users,
and they'll keep coming back.
Finally, it allows you
to share their experiences
with the rest of the Web.
So the idea behind that
is that if users are going
to your site and doing something
interesting there,
that you can actually use
Friend Connect to share
your site with the rest
of the Web
in a bunch of different ways.
So when we look at this,
and thinking back to the way of
how we're talking to platforms,
we can break down the
integration with Friend Connect
into three different ways.
And that's how I'm going
to be presenting today.
We let profile
come into the website.
At the website itself,
we add social functionality.
And then going out
of your website,
we have activities
and invites.
And then to simplify it
one more time,
it's basically who can access
your site without registering,
what can a user do
with their friends,
and where can users share
their actions
with the rest of the Web?
Now let's talk
about the INs first.
The goal here is to allow
a Friend Connect user
to log into your site as if
they were a registered user.
There's three things
we're gonna do.
We're gonna let them sign in,
we're gonna obtain
their social data,
and then we're gonna store it.
First of all,
you do need a little bit
of cut-and-paste code
to do a deep integration.
Basically, you need a button
to allow the user to click,
and then that will actually log
them into Friend Connect,
do all the UI work,
and then you can start pulling
their data
from your server.
Thankfully, this is actually
a very short piece of code.
Here it's listed in three--
I'm sorry, four lines.
Certainly easy.
And Chris here is actually
gonna show doing that demo
with the Plane Crazy site.
Schalk: Okay.
Thanks, Arne.
And, so, yes,
what I'm going to do
is basically show you
an application
that I'd been working on
just fairly recently
and that it actually uses
the same--
the technology
that we're describing.
So in this sense,
I'm showing you
the log-in page.
And then in this case,
I can click
on the sign-in button,
and that little bit
of JavaScript pops open,
and then I can actually log in
to this site
using my Google Friend Connect
account
or basically any,
essentially, account
through Google Friend Connect.
Okay?
So in that case, it's actually
a fairly simple process.
I'll go ahead and log in
to the site really quickly.
And so what it's doing
is, like, essentially,
if you look into the code,
a certain token
is passed to your browser
as a cookie
and then on the server side,
you can extract that cookie,
and then from then on,
you can start making requests
to the Google Friend Connect
server using standard...
RESTful protocol.
And in my case,
this is a Java application
that I'm running
on Google App Engine for Java.
And I'm using the Eclipse plugin
that you may have seen
in the keynote yesterday.
So once I obtained
the authorization
to connect to the Google
Friend Connect server,
I can start querying
social data,
and I can inject that
into the UI.
So I'll show you more
about this application
as we move on,
but just wanted
to kind of cover that
really quickly.
Roomann-Kurrik: Thanks.
So like Chris said,
we can actually pull data
from a server-to-server API.
And the way this is done
is through the OpenSocial set
of APIs,
which gives you two ways
of pulling data.
Basically, a REST request
or an RPC request.
What a lot of users
don't really realize is--
or what a lot of developers,
I'm sorry, don't really realize
is a lot of Friend Connect data
is actually public.
At least the data
that users sign in with.
And so it defaults
to public data.
So if you actually wanted
to check out
the public data for a site,
we actually have
a URL down here,
and if you follow that
with your browser right now,
you'll see an XML feed
of all the users
who have joined
The Chow Down sample site.
And looking at the structure
of this URL,
it's very straight-forward.
It's basically--you have
an endpoint for the API,
you do /people,
and then you do /@owner/@self.
The /@owner/@self
is a way to fetch
the site itself, so basically
when a Friend Connect site
is put into the context
of OpenSocial,
there's the idea
of the viewer and the owner,
and the site itself
is the owner,
so if you want to find out
the members of a site,
you'll look
for the owner's friends.
If you want to find out
who's actually using the site
currently,
then you'd look
for the viewer.
This symbol hopefully
is familiar to some of you.
It's a OAuth,
so when you're actually
making data requests,
and you need to establish
some sort of credentials
in order to fetch private data
or do activities,
your site gets issued
a Consumer Key
and a Consumer Secret.
You'll see that
in the Friend Connect UI,
so it's right there.
And then when you use
an OAuth library,
you can actually go fetch data
as if you were the site itself.
And this is really good
for background processing
because you can do it
at any time,
and you can do things
like post activities,
and you can read
and write app data.
And both of those
are actually covered
by the OpenSocial APIs
as well.
So say you want
to find out
who the current user
of your website is.
You actually have to get
user context.
So when the user logs in
like Chris said,
they actually have a cookie
that gets sent to your domain.
And it's called fcauth.
Fcauth actually just has
a security token inside of it.
And you can pass that
to an OpenSocial client library
and make requests for data,
do everything you would normally
be able to do
with an OpenSocial site,
so fetch people,
fetch app data,
update app data,
post activities,
et cetera.
You can see
that the Fcauth token
is really just a hash
of the user ID and the site ID,
so it gives you a context
of a user
on a specific site.
Now if you take URLs like
/api/people/@me/@self,
you can actually append
that fcauth token,
that value to it, and then when
you make that REST request,
you can actually get data
and perform activities
as if you were the user
interacting on your site.
So this is pretty powerful
because it lets you do things
that you normally
wouldn't be able to do.
Keep in mind, though,
the user has full control
over this,
so they have to join your site,
they have to actually configure
their site
to send activities, et cetera.
So they do have control still.
And Chris is now going
to show
getting the fcauth token
and making some requests.
Schalk: That's right.
I get to be demo wagon,
which is good because
we're actually going out
to a live site, and the network
was actually causing problems.
But fortunately a little
broadband card came in handy,
so, anyway...
so basically you want me
to show the fcauth token,
and I can quickly sign out
just to kind of explain
the process.
But as you log in,
what I've done
in my implementation,
I've created a servlet
that essentially processes
the log-in.
And as I switch over into
my Eclipse environment here,
I have essentially
the servlet right here
process [indistinct] log-in.
And all that does
is that just goes
and fetches the cookie off
of the browser,
and then once
I've obtained that,
I set that up
as an attribute
for my OpenSocial
client library.
And so what that does is that
essentially makes it available,
so then when I make
any future requests
to this OpenSocial container,
which is Google Friend Connect,
I can very easily fetch
all the data
that Arne was just referring to.
So that's all I do.
Once I obtain the cookie,
I set some of these attributes
onto the session,
and then from then on,
I can create pages,
do whatever I want,
access social data,
get my friends' data,
get thumbnail, URL,
all that kind of stuff.
It's all accessible
in my Java Web application.
Okay?
So I don't know
if there's any other things
I want to show,
but basically I'm just using
a servlet,
and then once I obtain
my information,
I just send it right off
to the Plane list.
Now I do have, like,
a little bit of code here.
Like, for example,
this method,
I'm just placing that
onto the session,
so that's
my profile information.
And then from then on,
I can take care of it.
Now the other thing
that is very important
is, like, if I'm a brand-new
user and I've just signed
into this application,
I actually go through
and check to see
if that brand-new Friend Connect
user exists or not.
And if he doesn't, I go ahead
and create a brand-new one.
So this actually gets
to the really important point
that, with Google Friend Connect
server-side integration,
you can actually have
an existing user registry,
as well as plug-in
Google Friend Connect,
and so kind of--you can have
the best of both worlds.
So if you recall
the sign-in page
that I had earlier,
you can have both of them
side by side
and have 'em work
in a somewhat equal experience.
But when you log in through
the traditional registry,
you just won't have access
to the social features.
But if you come in
through Friend Connect,
because you have access now
and declared
that I am a Friend Connect user,
you are setting that token.
Then you can actually inject
a whole bunch
of really cool features
into your Web application.
Social features, that is.
Okay.
Switch back.
Roomann-Kurrik:
So now that you're getting data,
how do you store it?
Basically, what I'll cover
is what kind of data
you'll be able to obtain
using the Friend Connect APIs.
And then I'll give you
some advice
about how you should structure
your data store.
To do this, we have to talk
about the different types
of users who might be accessing
your site,
so, like Chris said, you can
have locally-registered users.
These are the people that filled
out your registration form
and have native accounts
on your system.
They might also have
additional data,
such as site-specific
profile data.
For example,
what's my favorite airplane?
In terms
of the Plane Crazy site.
They probably don't have
friend data.
Friend data--friend models
are usually difficult
to implement, so your site
probably doesn't have one.
Google Friend Connect users,
they live in the Cloud.
Basically, they're
the aggregate set of users
from all
the different social networks
that Friend Connect supports.
And they just basically come
down in a consistent format
through the API.
You get a common set
of profile fields,
so you get a thumbnail URL,
you get a profile URL,
you get
a little "About Me" snippet,
just a small piece of text,
and you get
some custom URLs
that the user has defined.
So, for example,
maybe their Blogger URL.
Another important point
about this
is that they bring
their friends with them.
So the idea is, if
our Friend Connect is on a site,
they have very easy access
to invite their friends.
And, you know, word of mouth
and everything is good,
so having Friend Connect users
come into your site
will actually help, hopefully,
adoption.
The interesting thing to note
about this, though,
is that you can't store
this data forever.
When a user lives in the Cloud,
they might change
their profile information,
they might change their URLs,
et cetera,
when they're not logged
into your website,
so you're not aware
of these changes.
Basically, the smallest piece
of information
that you can consistently store
about a Friend Connect user
is just their ID number.
That's not so bad
because you have access
to this information
whenever you want,
so you can keep fetching it
from the REST APIs.
And you can obviously do
a little bit of caching
and everything to speed up
your website,
but keep in mind
that you only really have
this one number.
So when you're talking
or thinking about structuring
your database, you probably have
a table like this.
And on it is one set
of constantly incrementing IDs.
You know,
that's your user ID number.
After that
is a Google Friend Connect ID.
So we just added
an extra column
into this hypothetical example,
and we're storing that Google
Friend Connect user ID.
That way, we can look up a user
by either their local ID
or the Google Friend Connect ID
and pick the appropriate user
record according to that.
Finally, we have a little bit
of site-specific data,
so we have a user name.
That's the user name
that someone registered with.
So you can see that
there's actually a null entry
in the second row.
I'm sorry that the slide's
not very bolded here.
But if someone comes
to your site and registers,
they'll get a user ID.
But if a Google Friend Connect
user comes in,
they might not have one
because they never actually went
through that registration flow.
And then finally you see
a little bit
of that site-specific data
like I mentioned.
Here is
the person's favorite airplane.
So to show you
how we kind of build
a "my favorite airplane"
functionality into Plane Crazy,
Chris is going to do
another demo.
Schalk: So as we were discussing
what would be the best way
to kind of showcase this idea,
the notion of, okay,
let's go ahead
and select a favorite item here.
And so in this case,
if you notice the image there,
there's a little check box.
And what that means is that
this, for this particular user,
the Cessna 172SP happens
to be my favorite airplane.
And so I'm gonna go ahead
and change it.
I'm gonna click on the 152
actually.
Any pilots out there
in the audience?
Awesome.
Oh, cool.
We'll have to chat.
So anyway what I've done here
is I've curated essentially--
it's a facsimile
of what Arne showed earlier
with the Friend Connect gadget.
But I've kind
of reprogrammed it,
and now I have access
to the server-side.
So in this case,
when I click on this button,
select this plane
as your favorite,
what it's doing--
it's first updating
a column in my table
for my user
as I define
what my favorite plane is.
Plus, I do some UI stuff
just to indicate that
now the plane is my favorite.
But on the server side,
I do something else.
I also post an activity.
So I have, like,
a special activity log locally
But then I also go out
and use the Friend Connect API
to post the activity to,
essentially,
any connected network
that I specify for my account.
So that's a really cool concept
because I can then, you know,
essentially tell the world
that I've selected
this airplane.
And because Friend Connect uses
the OpenSocial standards
for essentially connecting
to other servers,
I can go
onto these other servers
and see what's available.
Let me show you a little bit
of the code,
just so you get
a basic idea.
So in this case
I just have, like,
a simple servlet that processes
the form information.
And as it goes through,
I have a bit of code
that sets the favorite item.
So in this case, I'm just using
the Java App Engine,
but this could be, you know,
any server-side technology
to store essentially
what the particular item
that I selected
as my favorite.
And that stores it
in my local registry.
And then I have this little call
here, postGFCActivity,
and all that does is
that sets up my call
out to OpenSocial,
and I call createActivity
off of essentially
the client object,
which is made available
through the OpenSocial
Java client library.
And once I fire that off,
that actually gets--
what's the word?
I keep thinking--
delegated
or essentially propagated out
to other social networks.
And I'll see also that, if
I click on my own profile here,
I can see,
even in my own activities,
that I've actually launched out
and declared the Cessna 152
as my favorite activity--
as my favorite item
in this case.
So it's a little bit of both.
I'm doing local activity
generation.
I'm keeping a log of it.
I can display
the local log right there.
But I can also post it
out to the world
and tell the world how it works.
That it?
Roomann-Kurrik:
So now that we have the idea
of how we're structuring
our data store,
we have the column
of user IDs,
of Google Friend Connect IDs,
let's just run
through a little flowchart
of how do we pick
the correct user?
And the first thing we do
is, upon a page load
to our authorization page
or our log-in page
or whatever,
we check for the presence
of this fcauth cookie.
Now if it's not there,
we basically look and see
if log-in credentials
are present.
Did someone access
this page
with their, you know, user name
and password
from a foreign post?
If they did,
then we select from users,
where the username is whatever,
and match the password.
If we actually get
a user back from that way,
then we have a local user.
We can use this record,
you know, key data off of it
locally.
If the user credentials
are not present,
then the user's not logged in.
Then we just redirect them
back to the log-in page,
et cetera.
Now the interesting thing
happens
is when we actually do have
an fcauth cookie
because what we do
is just a REST fetch
with a cookie
and then find out who @me is.
Then we sele--
if a record actually
comes back down the wire,
basically we look
at the Google Friend Connect ID
that comes back, and we look
into our users table again
to see whether there's a user
with the corresponding
Google Friend Connect ID.
If there is, then that person's
already visited our site.
They're probably already
interacted somehow,
and we have their record.
We can log 'em in.
But if they're not,
like Chris said,
the really interesting thing
is we just create a user,
we just put in an extra record,
we attach the Google
Friend Connect ID into that,
and then it's basically as if
they had already registered,
so they didn't actually have
to fill out any sort of form.
The process is the same as--
the log-in process is the same
the first time
as it is every time.
So to finish up the IN section,
the goal was to allow
a Friend Connect user
to log into the site as if
they were a registered user.
Hopefully, we showed you
that we let users log in
with the JavaScript button,
fetch data via social REST calls
to the OpenSocial
compatible endpoint.
We adapted our data store
to store
some ID information about Google
Friend Connect users,
and we created
an authorization flow
that let us pick
the corresponding row
out of our database.
Finally, we added--
you can add a little bit
of caching for performance.
Now it's the MIDDLE.
How do we make our site
more social?
And we have two goals here.
Let's use social signals
to highlight important content,
so let users on your site
discover content
that they wouldn't
normally discover.
And then we use content
to make new social connections,
so let people make new friends
on your site
in the context
of the data.
We're gonna do two simple steps:
add social chrome to our site,
and then we're gonna restructure
our views
to take advantage of extra data.
Social Chrome is actually
a very simple integration.
For example, Friend Connect
has the idea
that users have
their own profile.
So by adding
this canvas.html file,
one of the two files
we downloaded
when we set up the site,
you can actually render
a user's profile
for any Friend Connect user
on your website.
This is certainly customizable,
so here's an example
of two profile pages
for the same user
on two different sites.
It's customized to the UI
of the site itself.
What Chris was talking about,
we having the registration
or log-in page,
promoting signing in
with Google Friend Connect
is pretty important.
Give people the alternative of
filling out a registration form
by, "Hey, just click
this button."
So that actually
kind of makes it stand out.
It's a first-class citizen
on your website.
We can restructure our UI
a little bit
to take advantage
of social signals,
so depending on whether
the user's registered locally,
we'll just have
a Sign out button,
as you can see
on the top left corner there.
Otherwise...
I'm sorry. In addition to that,
we also show a little bit
of UI about,
"Hey, we have this thing
"called Google Friend Connect.
You can sign in
with your friends."
I'm sorry that this slide
is pretty small,
but basically it says we have
this ability for you to log in,
get your friends attached
to your profile,
and poke this button
and you can do that.
So we actually still allow
the option of signing
with Friend Connect, even though
they're signed in locally.
Now the next example
to the right of that
is a registered user with
a Google Friend Connect account.
Again, they're logged in.
They have a Google
Friend Connect account.
But for whatever reason,
you don't have an fcauth cookie.
So we're actually showing
an extra log-in link,
and this one, this time,
it's just another log-in link.
And they can click that
and actually just enable
their account.
And this lets you fetch friends,
do social posts of activity
and data, et cetera.
So the prompt here is actually,
"Hey, you're logged
"out of Friend Connect,
just click this button,
"and you'll be logged in,
and you'll have access
to this extra functionality
on our website."
Finally, at the very bottom,
is a Google Friend Connect user.
We've just added
a few extra links,
and these are links
that are provided
by the Friend Connect APIs.
But we don't really prompt them
'cause now we have access
to do anything we want
with this kind of user.
So talking about structuring
these buttons and log-ins,
you really want to give
incentives for logging in.
So you can--next to a piece
of content on your website,
you should give prompts,
like, "Share this
with your friends.
Log in
with Google Friend Connect."
Or "See what your friends
are doing." Et cetera.
And what's good
about the sharing
is when you integrate it
into your back end,
it's actually visible
to all users on your site too,
so, when you're actually
floating data on your views,
it will actually show you
how even users
who are not
Friend Connect-enabled
can actually see
that there's interactions
taking place
on your website,
and that might incentivize them
to log in.
And logging in,
like we talked about,
is pretty good
because it'll help them
bring their friends
into your site as well.
So, for example,
here's a simple social view,
basically showing what users
are on the site.
It's one of the easiest views
to implement.
Basically, you scroll
over the recent updates
on the list.
For example,
here on Plane Crazy,
we're showing the recent
favorites of someone
on the site, so when
someone goes through
and favorites something
on the site,
here's a hypothetical view
of, basically,
you know, here's
the last ten updates.
It's pretty interesting.
It's not that interesting.
But it does benefit social users
and Friend Connect users--
I'm sorry, Friend Connect users
and registered users the same.
In taking this in the context
of different sites,
maybe you want to float top
scores, highest-rated players,
recent updates, et cetera.
Now another interesting view
that you can surface
on your website--
and this is mostly to benefit
Friend Connect users--
is show them what their friends
have been doing on the website.
So, for example,
here's a hypothetical view
of the Plane Crazy site
where it shows what your friends
have favorited.
So here Lane, Steph, and Dan
like the Cirrus SR-22,
and Ryan and Patrick
like the Piper Warrior.
So now I can see, oh,
these friends of mine
have different tastes,
but I kind of get
some interesting signals
to drive me to these two planes.
Again, taking this
in the context
of maybe a different type
of site,
you can do things like,
"Are my friends playing
"any sort of game?
How do I rank
compared to my friends?"
Et cetera.
I'm sure your imagination
can come up
with some alternatives.
So you want to show "Building
my friends' favorite airplanes"?
Schalk: So in this case,
implementing, like, you know,
friend stuff is simply a query
in this case.
Because I have all the data
stored locally.
So if I wanted to say,
"What are
my friends' favorite planes?"
I'll just show you real quickly.
I'm just driving a query,
it pulls it
out of the data store,
and, essentially, these are
my friends' favorite planes.
And so, in this case,
Arne's plane is Cessna 172SP.
How's it work? Let me
just show you very quickly.
And this is just
a quick JSP example.
I do probably have a little bit
more logic inside the JSP
than I'm comfortable with.
But it's mostly
for demo purposes.
But in this case all I'm doing
is I'm making a call
out to the data store--
in this case, Java App Engine--
and just pulling back
essentially a list of,
well, first I fetch my friends.
So I know what list
of my friends are,
and then from that friend list,
I then go through
and compare, you know,
which friends actually have
the same favorite airplane.
And that's all they do.
Then render it out
to the page there.
I can fire off other queries
as well,
so, friends, favorite planes
in general.
So that just goes back
to my user registry,
my table of different users,
and just displays
what specifically
is their favorite airplane.
Okay?
I think I clicked on that twice.
Anyway, basically,
all I'm doing
is firing off different queries
and pulling it directly
from my local data store.
And I'm comparing that
with the same information
that I'm getting.
Oh, in this case,
we probably need
to put more friends on there,
but you get the idea.
Roomann-Kurrik:
Switching back here,
let's talk
about some more advanced
or intermediate types of views.
Keep in mind
that data in the context
of the site
is actually really valuable,
so when you're showing
a list of planes,
showing which friends
like that plane
next to that is a pretty
nice piece of functionality.
And it kind of helps users
who are browsing
around your site to actually see
pieces of content
that might be more interesting
than other pieces.
So, for example,
on the Plane Crazy site,
there's a Cessna 172,
and it shows, "Hey, three
of my friends like this plane.
"Well, I'm going to be
more inclined to click in
"and find out more about it.
Why do they like it so much?"
Obviously, you can think
about how this applies
to other sites too,
so, if you have a guitar site,
then maybe some of your friends
really like playing
this guitar or own this guitar.
If you're doing
a restaurant review site,
then, "Some of your friends gave
this restaurant a poor review."
So the signals
actually help users decide
what content's important,
what content isn't important.
To take that one step further,
we can actually make social data
available
that's not part
of your friends circle.
So when you're actually looking
at a plane,
if you were to see, "Hey, look,
there's five people
that I don't know that actually
really like this plane,"
and you actually got the context
of a discussion going on
about why they like this plane,
all of a sudden your site
becomes way more valuable.
If you actually know
that you can go to your site
to talk with people about planes
and find out,
"Hey, is this a good plane?
Do I want to try
to fly this?"
or whatever, then the experience
becomes much more valuable
in the sense that people
can only do that on your site.
Your site becomes
the destination for plane data.
And the good thing
about this is,
because of Friend Connect's
friending model,
you can actually find out
people who have similar tastes
and interests
on your site and befriend them.
You can actually make
new friends and contacts
through the website.
So do you want to show--
Schalk: I think I already showed
this next thing,
but if there's anything else
you want to cover on that.
Basically, I think I already
showed the advanced social views
where users who have already
favored this plane.
But, basically, clicking--
and like I said, the
implementation was quite easy
once I have
the data stored locally.
It was just a matter
of fetching my friends.
Oh, I need to actually have
some more data in there,
but, basically,
you get the idea.
I'm just fetching
from a local table
and pulling out
and rendering the data.
Roomann-Kurrik:
So it's simple, right?
Schalk: Mm-hmm.
Roomann-Kurrik:
So to summarize,
basically what we did
was we used social signals
to direct users
to appropriate content.
Again, we showed, you know,
socially what content
might be interesting,
and then finally,
we allow content to dictate
relationships on our site.
Something that Friend Connect's
really great at.
To do this, we made social users
first-class citizens.
We gave them their own UI.
We gave them log-in buttons
that were on the same level
as normal log-in buttons.
And we also changed
their data views,
so we actually showed data
that displayed activities
of people working on your site,
that we put friend data
into content,
and then we allowed a discussion
to happen
around the content
to allow users to interact
with each other.
The final part
of the presentation
is the OUTs, right?
How do we get data
out of our site?
And the goal here
is to let users share
their experiences
on your site
with the rest of the Web.
There's two major areas here
where we can actually improve
the site.
One is invites.
Another is activity streams.
So invites is actually part
of the Friend Connect UI
that's built in.
It's very easy to do.
You basically just render
one single link,
and a pop-up will come in
and let a currently logged-in
user invite their friends
to come join the site.
You can actually see
that they have
a kind of sharing tab,
which lets you share
the site data
with some of the most popular
social websites.
Listed up here is MySpace,
twitter, Delicious, Digg.
Basically, if people have
an interesting time
on your site, they're gonna want
to talk about it.
And Friend Connect gives you
a really simple way
to actually post data
back out to all of these sites.
In fact, it's one line of code.
The deeper integration, though,
is activity streams,
so, basically, most social
networks have the idea
of a stream of updates
that its users have been doing,
and when the user logs in,
they get an updated view
of what their friends
have been doing.
Friend Connect actually
gives you access to write
to some of these streams.
So what it does is sit
between you having to make
a call to each social network
that your users are on,
and you basically send
an activity to one endpoint,
and depending
on the users' configuration,
they can actually
post activities
out to several different sites.
Naturally, this depends
on user permissions, though,
because they don't want
activities going out,
they can turn that off.
Now the great thing
about this
is that social networks
are, like,
even if you're writing
to only a few outputs,
the way the social web
is kind of shaping up
is that this activity stream
kind of gets forwarded
and redistributed
around the Web.
One interesting thing
is I kind of have
my own social network profile
set up in a way that--
I use a service
called FriendFeed,
and when I do an update,
it actually aggregates
all of these updates.
And then I have
certain social network profiles.
Like, my Facebook profile
gets updated
every time
my FriendFeed account updates.
So, even though I might share
something on one site,
FriendFeed picks it up,
then Facebook picks it up,
and it's kind of like
this circular dependency
of activities that kind
of just keeps multiplying,
multiplying.
So kind of feeding data
into that system
is really useful
because it means
there's a lot of eyeballs
on the content
that you're posting out there.
And if people--
if anyone kind of--
if that content
resonates with anyone
and someone finds it
interesting,
they're gonna follow that link
back to your site.
And then they're gonna interact,
and they're gonna bring
their friends,
and it's kind of like
a virtuous cycle
where the OUTs actually feed
data back into the INs
of your website.
And it's a great way
to drive adoption, I'd say.
All right, to show you
how easy it is
to post an activity,
here's a simple REST call.
I had to use curl
because we have to do a post,
so you can't really just access
it directly in your browser.
But you can actually see,
following
the OpenSocial API model,
it's /activities/@me/@self.
You put in the fcauth token.
And then you just post a JSON
object into the activity API.
You can see it here.
It's encoded so I can
just use it from a text input.
But I gave it a title,
I gave it a body
and then ran the curl command.
Curl posted it,
and then, that's it.
That's all I have
to worry about.
Now you can see that these kinds
of activities show up
in Friend Connect-enabled
websites as well,
so this is a view
in the context of a site itself.
It shows what all the users
on that site have been doing.
So this is one of those gadgets
that you can install quickly
onto your website.
You can also provide
a deeply integrated view,
you know, by making a REST call
to fetch the activities
for your site.
One great thing about it
is if you have kind of like
some of the easier
Friend Connect pieces,
a lot of these activities
surface automatically.
For example, they're visible
in the Members Gadget.
The even more interesting thing
about this
is that activity updates
are viewable
across every single Google
Friend Connect site.
So basically when you post
an activity,
someone on a completely
different site might see it.
So considering
that there are millions
of Google Friend Connect sites,
that gives you a lot of exposure
through this method as well.
You want to show activities?
Schalk: Sure. Sure.
Roomann-Kurrik: Cool.
Schalk: So one of the things
that I did do,
I went back,
and then I did a quick browse
of the airplanes.
And then I noticed that,
by looking at all my friends'
favorite planes,
I was then able
to select the Cessna 172
as my favorite plane
right there.
So that when I do, essentially,
a query
on the Friends with same
Favorite Plane as Me,
I'll see that there are
at least three of my friends
that also have
the same favorite friend.
So just to kind of finish
that one off,
or at least you
and a cute teddy bear seemed
to like my same plane selection.
Now getting back
to the activities.
So if I go back--as I kind
of did a quick demo earlier,
but I can drill down
a little bit more.
So say if I want to go back
to the Cessna 152...
As I showed you this before,
basically, I implemented this
so it does two things.
It actually stores, like,
a local copy
of this, you know, plane
as my favorite,
and I have essentially
a column in my table
that says
it's my favorite plane.
And I'm also keeping that handy
so then I can render it
down here.
So now we have a log of, like,
different people
that are favoriting
this particular airplane.
And so this log is based
on each different plane.
And so the cool thing
about the activities,
and I'll just show you the code
once I fire it off,
is it's actually quite simple.
I think it's--
I covered it mostly,
but basically, it's just
a matter of--
in my case,
since I'm using Java--
I'm just using the OpenSocial
Java Client Library.
And I set up my call,
and it's called
client.createActivity.
And that's all I really need
to do at that point.
The activity itself
gets sent off,
and I have a little bit
of logic here that,
you know, if you didn't enter
a comment,
it would just have
a customized comment for you.
Or you can actually type it
into the field,
and it will send it there.
But other than that, it's
actually very straightforward.
And the cool thing is that,
now--
well, my particular user ID,
I've maxed out my quota
for sending out activities,
but if you do the same thing,
you can actually go out
to Plaxo or Netlog
and find this same application
instance activity
is also being sent out
to these other
partner websites as well.
That's a really--I love
that feature of Friend Connect.
It's a great way
to have viral spread
of your application, and
your application doesn't have
to be, like, in a typical
OpenSocial container.
In this case,
it's an actual website, so...
Anyway...
Roomann-Kurrik: Great.
So to recap, we wanted to let
users share their experiences
on this site
with the rest of the Web.
And we did that two ways.
We gave them
invite functionality
through the Friend Connect
pop-up,
where they could just post
information
back to other websites,
and then we used activity
streams to kind of drive data
deeply into
other social networks.
So, in conclusion,
we had a few goals,
which we accomplished
by integrating deeply
with Friend Connect.
It wasn't very difficult.
Basically we want to allow
Friend Connect users' log-in.
We did that
through a JavaScript button,
which gave the UI flow
for a user logging in,
established a cookie
on our site
where we were able to pull
social data,
and then establish
a data store model
around that social data.
We use social signals
to highlight content.
So we put in social Chrome,
kind of floated friend data
into the UI of our site,
and we also put in data
about social users around the
content of the site as well.
And finally we used invites
and activities